les rôles principaux du biopic de
grégory lemarchal ont été annoncés vous
savez que rhin biopic sur tf1 les
dernières heures on a appris que le
comédien michael lumière âgé de 23 ans
voilà a été a choisi lui pour
interpréter le rôle de grégory vous
savez clément rémy ans de tf1 avait
refusé le poste on sait pas trop si
c'était un problème d'emploi du temps ou
quoi donc voilà c'est ce garçon là c'est
moi ressemblant mais à défaut tous ses
cheveux frisés en changeant les cheveux
peut-être mais là là c'est pas sinon
avec un bond des frissons défrisage
pardon c'est absolument nous la
permanente c'est fascinant quand même
les frais et on a le nom des parents
aussi à vous savez qu'ils jouent les
parents c'est sorti hier nous ducret
absolument et audi lui il m'a donc voilà
c'est parce que dans la série parce
qu'on sait que les parents sont aussi
très très alcoolisée dedans il peut ils
vont choisir aussi moins souvent que tu
as trop demandant un scénario et que
chacun impose un peu ces conditions
parfois la fin on est déçus entendu car
je pense qu'elle est un énorme carton
sur tf1 je ne sais pas ce qu'en pensez
vous série va faire ce qu'ils voient
jouer dans une série
je ne sais pas si karine ferri mettre
dedans ou pas peut-être côté ça fait
cinquante bus jusqu'à jusqu'à la star ac
je crois qu'ils vont faire avait aussi
dans les causes que je sais on y
travaille est parce que nos lauréats
étaient des gens très précis on me dit
que ça lui était proposé en tout cas et
qu'on n'a pas sa réponse
moi je pense ce serait bien qu'elle joue
dedans parce que pour le coup karine
ferri je vous dis la vérité moi je
l'avais vu un week-end on a passé un
week-end ensemble c'était après la mort
de grégory lemarchal
on peut aimer ou pas aimer karine ferri
elle était dévastée tout le week-end
mais tout le week-end elle était elle
était en échange elle pleurait elle
était c'était vraiment vraiment vraiment
l'amour de sa vie
donc s'il ya bien une chose qu'on pût ce
pas sur les normes et est ce que le
biopic baba jusqu'à l'histoire s'arrête
avant s'ils s'arrêtent à moi je sais pas
où ça ira et on verra bien